Apollo is the uh the 22nd number one
pick to win Rookie of the Year honors he
averaged 20.7 rebounds wow four assists
he shot 43 percent 30 percent from Deep
and the guy's only 20 years old how
about his season chuckster I thought he
was fabulous all year you know he he's I
actually got an opportunity to meet him
in Las Vegas when we were out there for
the match I couldn't believe his size
but you can never judge these guys till
you actually see him in person because
everybody lies about their size and
height I was like man he's got a great
body to be 18 19 years old and he was
fabulous all year and they got some nice
building pieces down there in Orlando
what'd you think of the of the rookie
season for the guy who goes to that
school in Durham or went to that school
in Durham yeah he's one of the few guys
that I do appreciate that come from that
school no he had a fabulous year his
ability to um
score on three levels uh threes off the
dribble
uh penetration can post up and um became
a better Defender as the season went on
and a great young team
that he's playing with so his his
ability to get better
instead of guys playing you know playing
with Cole Anthony and Jalen uh uh slugs
and guys who were who are not playing
for stats I think helped him become a
better player as well what do you say we
talked to the uh oh great Ikea NBA
Rookie of the Year let's do that Paulo
mancaro joins us now and uh we
congratulate you Apollo on uh on your on
your honors you got a full house in
there man that's uh that's nice who's
who's all in attendance here for this
announcement
man we got uh my mom my sister right
there uh
to my friends from home and then just
the people around the magical who helped
me get this done yeah you mentioned you
mentioned your mom uh Rhonda who played
professionally as well was reading an
old article uh about you growing up and
the lessons about the game that she
taught you take me into that a little
bit
yeah uh she taught me a lot of lessons
man uh some hard ones
um but now she always just stressed you
know the fundamentals first putting
those first
um you know we worked on a lot of boring
stuff growing up uh drop steps using the
backboard using her left hand
um and just putting the work first that
was one thing she always made sure I was
doing was active and working on my game
and uh everything else was going to take
care of herself
Apollo Shack here first of all uh
congratulations to you and your family
secondly when you were drafted by the
Orlando Magic did you say to yourself
I'm going to be rookie of the air no
matter what it takes
what's up Shaq uh you know no I
definitely did I remember when I first
got drafted on my agent Mike Miller who
also on rookie of the year for the magic
uh you know he looked at me and he asked
me if I could if I was gonna be Rookie
of the Year and you know I constantly
say Yes
um it was just a goal I've always had
something I had my eye on from the
second I got drafted so I'm glad I was
able to do it
number one uh congratulations on a
fantastic rookie season I mean you're
the other than Dwight Howard you're
another great Orlando big man uh it's
just a you know it's not meant a great
big man in Orlando says you suck it
already behind the white but let me ask
you a question seriously what was the
hardest part of your rookie year
I think the hardest part for me was uh
really going through a rough stretch um
in the middle of the Year where I was
struggling a lot up and down games and
just having to get through it it lasts
for about a month and I was just
frustrated you know a lot of just
talking with myself talking with my
coaches
um trying to figure out you know how I
could be playing better and you know I
just stuck with it stayed in the gym and
uh you know they they didn't lose any
trust in me and I was able to bounce
back and you know finish the year off
strong